let's review what happened in the last
video because in general it's just kind
of confusing and it's always good to see
it a second time and then we could think
a little bit about how these market
dynamics could be manipulated so that
you don't have the Chinese currency
getting more expensive so in the last
video we started off with an exchange
rate of 10:1 per dollar we saw that this
manufacturer over here in China had to
sell his goods for the equivalent of 10
watt in order for him to make a profit
that this guy in the United States had
to sell his goods abroad or we'll say in
China for the equivalent of $1.00 now
this exchange rate this price was $1 one
u.s. dollar in the United States and at
this exchange and at this exchange rate
this guy had to sell his Cola for 10:1
so that he could get his dollar so we
kind of just drew it out the guy would
send and we said at that price so for
10:1 which was one dollar at one dollar
there was demand for $100 in the United
States so we saw this dynamic he would
ship a hundred dollars to the United
States and then the United States would
ship him back a hundred dollars he would
sell those dolls for essentially a
dollar each he would get back a hundred
dollars on the other side of the
equation
the cola manufacturer what if he were to
sell it for 10:1 in China there's demand
for 50 cans of soda so he would send 50
cans of soda to China and they would
send him ten one for each can 500 won
now what happened in that situation is
that the Chinese manufacturer had a
thousand won that he needs to convert
into dollars into $100 preferably a fee
if that exchange rate were fixed the
American manufacturer and let's say
these are the only two the only two
actors in our scenario has 500 one that
needs to convert into $50 so if we just
look over here here's someone who wants
to convert 1000 won he wants to he or he
wants to convert into 1000 won let me be
very careful he wants to convert his
hundred dollars into 1000 won if the
currency were to be held constant
but there's only 501 being offered in
the market there's only 501 being
offered in the market so he was going to
have to offer more dollars per one than
he would if there was more one in the
market now you can look at the other
side this am an American manufacturer
has 500 won from his sales in China he
wants to convert it if the currency was
pegged into $50 but maybe he could do
better than $50 here and as we can see
there's more demand to convert the 1
than there is to convert the dollars he
wants to buy $50 using one this guy this
guy wants to sell this wants to sell
$100 into one so if you look over here
the supply supply of dollars supply of
dollars is much greater than is much
greater than the demand then the demand
for dollars and you know in anything if
the supply of apples is greater than the
demand for apples then the price of
Apple's would go down and the opposite
is happening here with the one the
demand for one this is the demand the
demand for one is much greater than the
supply of one then the supply and we
know that when the demand is greater
than the supply the price needs to go up
and so we saw a Senate scenario where
the price of the dollar will go down in
terms of 1 now all that means is if you
have to give 10:1 per dollar now you're
gonna have to give fewer one per dollar
the price of the one was good go down if
the price of Apple's in Wan's goes down
instead of offering a 10 Apple 10 one
per Apple you probably offer 8 one per
Apple so we see the exact same thing for
the price of the dollar but that's
equivalent to saying that the price of a
1 goes up and we said eventually and I'm
just making this number up it's hard to
predict what the actual settling price
would be we eventually get to eight one
per dollar and then we said at that
exchange and actually I'm going to
change the numbers a little bit just to
make it a little bit cleaner at that
exchange rate at 8 1 per dollar these 10
and all these 10:1 dolls would now cost
$1 25 and let's say that at $1 25 in the
United States there is demand for 60 let
me make that there's demand for $60 I'm
changing the numbers a little bit from
the last video just to make the numbers
work out a little bit better so you
could just ignore the numbers from the
last video and remember the old demand
when the 10:1 dolls were only $1 so the
old demand old demand old Amman we have
it up here was a hundred dolls was 100
100 dolls so it makes sense if dolls are
$1.00 people are going to buy we are
going to have more of them if dolls go
up to a dollar 25 the demand will go
down and say they'll go down to 60 dolls
now on the other side of the equation
the $1 can of soda at 8 one per dollar
will now sell in China for 8 1 and
remember remember what the old price was
the old price in China when the currency
rate was 10 to 1 was 10 1 so the price
so the let me write it here the price
the price of the cola went from 10 1 10
one down to down to 8 1 so the demand
now that the cola is cheaper in China
the demand went up and I'll change this
number too so don't do the 80 cans we'll
say that the demand the demand in China
went from 50 cans we saw that up here he
had to ship 50 cans when it costs 10 won
per can so it went from 50 cans up to
and maybe I should make it go up the
demand went from 50 up to let's say 75
cans 70 75 cans just like that I'm using
these numbers because it's going to lead
to cleaner numbers so now what is the
actual scenario and the last video I
said work it out yourself but I realize
the more concrete examples of this the
more it'll kind of sink into your brain
so now what is the trade balance going
on so going from China so if we look at
so China China and then you have the you
is China and the US over here we're
going to be shipping we are now going to
only be shipping 60 dolls so 60 60 dolls
and then the u.s. is going to ship back
60 times a dollar 25 that is $75 right
one dollar 25 for 60 dolls means you're
going to get $75 so 75 US dollars are
going to go back to China so that's due
to the dolls and I'll let's think about
what's going to happen due to the soda
we are going to have we're going to have
75 cans of soda 75 cans of soda let me
write 75 cans are going to be shipped to
China and then China is going to send
back what 75 cans at eight at eight one
per can at eight one perk and 75 times
eight is 75 times eight is what is that
seven it's 55 six it's 600 so for those
75 cans he is going to get back 601 he
is going to get back 600 601
so now what's happening the Chinese
manufacturer over here on the Left wants
to convert so wants or needs to convert
wants to convert wants to convert what
does he have he has $75 wants to convert
$75 into if we assume that a with the
currency is now eight and he says well
just get it at the market rate into
roughly 600 one into six hundred one
right 75 times eight is 75 times eight
is six hundred eight ones per dollar and
then the u.s. manufacturer wants to
convert once to convert wants to convert
he's got 601 601 from his sale of soda
into and if he assumes he can get kind
of the last market rate 600 divided by
eight is into $75 $75 so what
just happened here now the supply of
dollars this is the supply of dollars is
equal to the demand for dollars and also
the supply of one the supply of one
right over here is equal to the demand
for one so now we are depending how you
view it we're sending the same dollar
value to the US as we're sending back to
China or we're sending the same one
China and the currency has has is now in
balance it really shouldn't shift and so
I want I really wanted to go through
this example again to show you that when
you have freely floating currencies
eventually the the trade should one
currency should get more if there is a
trade imbalance one currency will become
more expensive than the other until the
demand equalizes in both countries so
that you eventually do have a trade
balance hopefully that doesn't confuse
you too much in the next video we'll
talk about how a government and we'll
talk about the Chinese central bank in
particular could intervene so that this
doesn't happen so that they can always
ship more to the US than the US ships to
China